and I will tell you the right guy always
stands out like there's never been an
Olympic Games in in the history of the
world where reach out when I slap Stevo
as we're watching something like I could
have won this yeah I set this Olympics
out it doesn't work that way there's
never been a World Series we're so well
you know I could have done this I didn't
want to play this year the right guys
will always come forward now number two
and three and five and ten maybe not but
the gold the best will always step
forward and take his credit except for
uh Simone Beals I remember you uh I
loved your takeoff yes because it was
the truthful one right disrespectful to
all the big worked so hard to be in the
Olympics and then
she's just gonna not compete you yeah
you well the bigger problem is you know
and she was having some mental issues
with that so the rumor goes is that in
America she has a prescription for
Ritalin
Tokyo's who hosted the Olympics and if
you fly in there with ritalin it's it's
a banned substance like we would say
with say cocaine just by example so she
didn't bring her medication and it did
play some tricks on her mind and and I
do believe that I do accept that what
bothered me is where she was being
praised she was taken a bow for the
strength it took strength to stand aside
and put my health in front of sport like
oh my God no it didn't and then I
watched all these other gymnasts that
were worried about taking on Simone so
they all said oh hey Bravo somebody was
like no absolutely not that was a weak
move it was a terrible move if you would
have said this a week ago we could have
flown somebody else over that had the
opportunities there were we got all
these girls that are sitting around for
another four years begging for the spot
that you've got and you're there and
you're not gonna make the walk come on
get out of the way yeah I love that do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt hole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and stevos butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah I do